the White House believes Special Counsel
Robert Muller will interview President
Trump in the next few weeks Muller's
questioning would focus on possible
obstruction of justice in the firing of
FBI director James Comey the President
and other Republicans claimed there's
bias in that investigation and it
extends to missing text messages sent by
two FBI officials who worked on the
Russia probe the president tweeted this
last night where are the 50,000
important text messages blaming Samsung
Paula Reid is outside the FBI
headquarters in Washington with the
latest on this story
Paula good morning good morning actually
50,000 text messages have been found but
the president is correct that the FBI is
still missing five months of text
messages exchanged between two FBI
officials who have been accused of bias
now CBS News confirmed special counsel
Robert Muller has interviewed Attorney
General Jeff Sessions and former FBI
director James Comey the White House
says the president is also eager to
speak with Special Counsel something
they say would signal that this
investigation is wrapping up Attorney
General Jeff Sessions is the first of
the president's cabinet known to be
interviewed by special counsel Muller no
I didn't but I'm not at all concerned
but the president didn't seem too
worried yesterday when asked about the
meeting earlier this month President
Trump discounted the idea of being
interviewed himself it has been
determined that there is no collusion
and by virtually everybody so we'll see
what happens I think the president has
to be concerned
Kim Whaley is a former federal
prosecutor who is an independent
counselor during the Whitewater
investigation what kind of information
can Attorney General Sessions offer to
the special counsel he could either be a
subject or target of the investigation
himself or he could be giving
information about people higher up in
government and where what we have is the
vice president the president maybe the
president's children and mr. Kushner as
Muller's investigation moves along the
campaign to undermine him is also moving
full steam ahead what this is all about
is further evidence of
corruption more than bias but corruption
at the highest levels of the FBI
Republicans are seizing on the
revelation that the FBI failed to
preserve many text messages during a
critical five month period during a
Russia investigation somebody needs to
watch those who watch us but Senate
Intelligence Chairman Richard Burr tamp
down any conspiracy theories Senator
Chuck Schumer says the focus on text
messages is an attempt to divert
attention away from the Moller
investigation
he shouldn't be thwarted in any way and
the diversion that they're trying to do
both with mauler and with others is not
good for the country
the president's lawyers are currently
working with Special Counsel to define
the terms of any possible presidential
interview to decide whether he would be
interviewed in person or answer
questions in writing or some combination
of both Norah all right Paula thank you
so much